president biden's spinning his chaotic
exit from afghanistan as an
extraordinary success as his
administration refuses to rule out
working with the taliban in the future
privately administration officials say
they're horrified over abandoning
americans one telling politico quote i'm
absolutely appalled and literally
horrified we left americans there it was
a hostage rescue of thousands of
americans in the guise of a neo
non-combatant evacuation operations and
we have failed that no fail mission
biden's chief of staff ron klain doing
his best however to paint a rosy picture
it's easy to second guess but let's just
be clear america was in this war for 20
years and i think any effort to unwind
that any effort to bring our troops out
any effort to end our military presence
in afghanistan was going to be filled
with
heartbreaking scenes and difficulties
and i think the biden administration has
manage that as well as it can be managed
under the circumstances we were placed
in
meanwhile the taliban showed off while
decked out in billions of dollars of u.s
military equipment and the baby
administration is still not working not
ruling out working with the terror group
in the future
what is the taliban are they now our
frenemy are they our adversary are they
our enemy are they are what are they
well it's hard to put a label on it as
far as our dealings with them at that
airfield or in the past year or so
in war you do what you must
in order to reduce risk to mission and
force not what you necessarily want to
do
any possibility of coordination against
isis k with him
it's possible
oh man that was upbeat all right evil
shannon thank you for uh taking the time
out to come here with you um so he calls
it president biden calls it an
extraordinary success but you can only
apply that phrase if you apply to a very
narrow
space like getting like we got the plane
in the air that's it because you have if
you if you uh incorporate the horrifying
process and the loss of life how can you
say that well groups also classifying it
as an extraordinary success china yeah
russia iran i mean we have to be uh very
cognizant of how this plays on the world
stage because clearly there are a number
of people who are cheering including
other terror groups in the taliban
saying this is a defeat of the u.s
but when you hear them say we did the
best we could with the situation that we
have i looked at this letter that came
out a couple of days ago from 90 some
retired generals admirals other top
military officials who say you can't
tell me that general milly and that
secretary austin thought this was the
best plan ever if they didn't fully push
back against this president and say this
was a terrible idea they should resign
or they should resign now people need
some kind of accountability because to
say that and they go back to the pivot
of like it was time to leave we all
almost everybody agrees on that it's not
about that it's how we left and if our
military leaders really gave this
president this advice and said this was
the best scenario then we we need some
answers yeah it's they're continuing
with the bait and switch nobody's
debating the decision to leave it was
how it was pulled off will which was
everybody agrees was horrifying
one thing they don't talk about as much
anymore are the allies we understand
that the americans are still there but
what about our allies that we left
behind they were there to help us and we
just
you know we left so much behind and it's
interesting that they qualify this as a
success greg by ignoring what we left
behind what they're looking at is the
hundred thousand that were evacuated
ignoring the thousand two thousand three
hundred whatever the number may be that
we left behind that has all the hope of
a doctor walking in and telling you know
what you're 90 cancer free that's not an
encouraging statement coming from your
doctor brought to you by the way from
the people with the same mindset that
said here's a mostly peaceful riot they
have a way not of seeing the silver
lining but of creating the silver lining
so i would suggest you ignore them
listen to the silent voices or the
anonymous voices in their administration
listen to the obama administration
officials who are throwing them under
the bus listen to our vets that say our
standard is leave no man behind
and more importantly don't act like this
is a catastrophe that you accidentally
stepped into on the sidewalk you created
this catastrophe it is your burden and
your obligation to ensure that no
american is left behind there's no
spinning no lying no creating a pseudo
reality out of that they have the
benefit too of that it doesn't seem the
media are actively seeking out anonymous
sources the way they did with trump
there would be hundreds of them right
now if this were trump geraldo speaking
of allies being left behind you have uh
you had a a um a serious issue with your
your past interpreter has there been any
news or here he is that's him right next
to me that's akbar shinwari he was 18
years old when we met him he was a
brother he begged us to go to craig on
the left
but akbar begged us to go with him uh
you know
take us uh take him with us back in the
torabora days he stayed with us the
entire time 12 assignments in
afghanistan is a wonderful guy we were
so worried about getting him out but fox
news did an excellent job under jay
wallace's leadership we really got
virtually all of our people out
and many of the other networks did the
same i mean it is because it's news when
things go badly the fact that this went
right and we got this dear friend uh out
and hopefully he'll my family and i will
sponsor him here in the united states we
look forward to his arrival here uh but
you know what they should move in with
you geraldo but i i i i said that i will
sponsor them either he'll live i see a
reality show i live next door i see a
reality show but one one point i want to
make is that jfk up to the bay of pigs
humiliation when he took credit said uh
victory has a hundred fathers defeat is
an orphan and that's what you're seeing
now you're saying you know let's laser
focus on the thing we did right getting
the 120 000 people out like akbar and
they did uh you know they did get it was
one of the most magnificent air lifts in
the history of uh of the human race
what went badly however and and we're
going to live with it it's going to
stick in our craw is watching these uh
these people who were savages and brutes
and were our enemies strutting around
wearing our clothes i mean it's going to
be very very difficult for us to bear
we're not programmed for it uh but it is
our new reality you know david this
something that drives me crazy is that
we keep saying that we have this or the
administration keeps saying we have this
enormous leverage
with the taliban
you know because we have these frozen
assets or whatever they're referring to
but it feels like we are we're basically
telling them to extort us like we're
actually being our own extortionists
we're saying you know what feel free to
hamper the withdrawal until we get until
we give you money that's kind of what
we're saying go ahead we're going to
give you money if you uh if you enable
us to get these people out
we have treasure but they have blood
right we found out a majority of the
interpreters other u.s visa applicants
were left behind in afghanistan wall
street journal reporting today a
majority
and then we found out that at least 500
journalists from radio for europe and
radio liberty among other government
agencies 500 journalists and their
families were also left behind so i i
it was too much to expect president
empathy i thought that was always a joke
but instead we got commander in
callousness
biden and company and
all of these democrats have displayed a
real
total lack of respect and regard for the
american people it's the same rubes and
rednecks and the flyover folks but they
are looking at you know they're dishing
out washington bio waste they're looking
at the american people and telling
demonstrable lies over and over and over
again and anybody who has the capability
of hearing and seeing knows that they're
being lied to and these like yesterday
could couldn't have gone better and i
think one of the reasons that millie
general milley and sec def austin did
only took three questions today is
because they're trying to avoid being
put in a situation where they have to
either lie for the president or tell the
american people the truth and the most
dangerous thing to me is
joe biden clearly is acting like a
one-term president he doesn't give a
damn and it is scorched america it is
scorched afghanistan it's a scorched
future because he won't be around when
the next terror attack arrives on our
shores
also just before we go ron mcclain
saying it's easy to second guess we
should have been second guessing more we
should have been first guessing we
probably wouldn't bet in this mess if
more people were engaged including
myself than that you know uh
it was the absence of second guessing
that let this unfold for so long and
then end like this i do think that leaks
though it won't be the journalists going
to the insiders they're going to be
like texting
you know when one cockroach comes out
then that's when they all show up but
you were referring to the war itself 20
years right of lies that we exactly
diverted our glance from exactly exactly
and how often did we hear about friendly
fire casualties and things the the ugly
side of the wall yeah second-guessing a
political candidate was one of the least
vetted in american history as well
true hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else